schön dass ihr dabei seid zdf heute live
china hat es angedroht und nun auch wahr
gemacht einen tag nachdem die us
politikerin nancy pelosi taiwan besucht
hat hat die chinesische regierung
militärmanöver rund um taiwan gestartet
auch raketen wurden abgefeuert fünf
davon sollen sogar im meer in einem
gebiet das als wirtschaftszone von japan
eigentlich geld runter gegangen sein und
auch taiwan das sehen wir auch gleich
hier in den bildern zeigt dass sie sich
verteidigen können und auch wollen das
taiwanesische verteidigungsministerium
erklärte das militär werde seine
alarmbereitschaft weiter erhöhen wir
sehen also schießübungen und da wird
also schon für den ernstfall geübt bis
sonntag soll das chinesische manöver
rund um taiwan noch dauern und china
will zeigen taiwan gehört zu uns und
wenn es so kommen sollte zur not würden
sie auch mit gewalt durchsetzen wollen
das natürlich taiwan zu ihnen gehört
taiwan hingegen versteht sich als
unabhängig und das ist ein großer streit
deswegen das thema bei uns heute manöver
um taiwan wie groß ist die gefahr und
was aktuell passiert ist heute hat unser
korrespondent ulf röller für uns
zusammengefasst
es sind diese bilder die chinas führung
in die welt senden will raketenabschuss
in richtung taiwan mit scharfer munition
finden die manöver stadt die insel ist
die nächsten drei tage umzingelt peking
plant eine see- und luftbad um seinen
besitzanspruch deutlich zu machen für
peking gehört taiwan zu festlandchina
im chinesischen staatsfernsehen erklären
militärexperten dem chinesischen volk
den einsatz
das manöver betrifft eine ganze reihe
von wichtigen militärischen regionen so
wollen wir die
unabhängigkeitsbestrebungen der
taiwanesischen separatisten unterbinden
china lässt die muskeln spielen eine
droh gäste auch an amerika das sich als
schutzmacht taiwans empfindet der besuch
von pelosi wirkt in taiwan nach
23 millionen menschen leben hier viele
haben angst vor krieg
taiwans
verteidigungsminister ausbricht wissen
wir nicht was wir tun sollen
taiwans regierung versucht diese angst
ihre bevölkerung zu nehmen sie hat ihr
militär in alarmbereitschaft versetzt
wir werden unsere selbstverteidigung
hochfahren erklärt taiwans sprecherin
des außenministeriums und uns eng mit
unseren verbündeten wie amerika
absprechen
china übt mit scharfer munition und
versetzt eine ganze region in den
ausnahmezustand
ihr könnt nun eure fragen stellen und
kommentieren im stream oder auch per
mail an unseren experten der heute abend
bei uns ist es ist prof professor
maximilian der halle er ist aktuell
gastprofessor an der land in school of
economics und er hat auch in china
geforscht und ist militärexperte und
heute bei uns zu gast
hatte halle wir haben eben gerade die
bedrohlichen bilder in den einspielern
und im beitrag auch gesehen das manöver
soll bis sonntag dauern die viele sorgen
muss sich taiwan denn jetzt gerade ganz
aktuell machen in den nächsten tagen
naja wir sehen dass die chinesen in den
letzten 17 jahren seit 2005 die größte
marine in ostasien aufgebaut hat größer
als alle anderen staaten und größer als
die amerikanischen navy in der region
das kreiert natürlich furcht die ich in
hessen haben in den letzten jahren eine
strategie entwickelt und ich war nicht
das unter experten
also ein der versuch einen möglichen
unterstützer taiwans also die usa daran
zu hindern sitzen blockieren zu hilfe
taiwans zu kommen und das ist genau das
wovor die taiwaner natürlich am meisten
angst haben nicht dass der eigentliche
stärke schutzmacht die usa das nicht
können und das sei bisher kamen gerade
so die lebenslinie wenn man so will für
die für die insel deshalb die furcht und
die furcht wird jetzt befeuert durch die
manöver die china natürlich sehr
geschickt hier durchziehen wir haben
auch mal eine karte vorbereitet damit
wir alle mal sehen können dass das ja
eigentlich sehr sehr nah beieinander
liegt taiwan und china vielleicht können
wir jetzt auch mal kurz einblenden
taiwan versteht sich als eine demokratie
unabhängig von oder taiwan ist dann
demokratie versteht sich als unabhängig
von china wir können ist jetzt hier
sehen also taiwan sehr dicht dran am
chinesischen festland tatsächlich nur
eine meerenge teilt die insel und das
festland und da stellt sich natürlich
jetzt auch die frage wie groß die gefahr
ist auch aufgrund dieser nähe weil jetzt
auch gerade wir haben es schon gehört
auch im beitrag und auch in der
anmoderation schon am anfang auch jetzt
gerade in dieser meerenge die ja
eigentlich eine friedliche zone ist wo
wirtschafts handelsverkehr betrieben
wird auch die ist ja jetzt
beeinträchtigt im zweifel bis sonntag
auch gerade durch diese nähe wie groß
ist die gefahr deshalb
jetzt in den nächsten tagen eine
einschüchterung ein angst machen
großmacht gegen einen kleinen staat der
seine freiheit schützen will sehen wir
werden aber keine invasion sehen
wir sehen dass der chinesische
staatspräsident
nicht im herbst in wenigen monaten in
seine dritte amtszeit als in einer maroh
ähnliche dauerstellung sich
inthronisieren lassen will und davor
diesen krieg nicht beginnen wird er
nutzt natürlich jetzt den pelosi besuch
um von seinem schlechten abschneiden in
der cockpit bekämpfung aber auch vor
allem in dem zentralen haben negative um
das ist das wirtschaft hier wachst du
nicht das wirtschaftliche wachstum ist
ja der goldstandard gegen den die
akzeptanz der chinesischen partei und
damit der führung in peking gesehen wird
so das würde jetzt sehr deutlich
versuchen zu kaschieren und komplizieren
durch starkes nationalistisches
auftreten ein krieg werden wir jetzt
noch nicht sehen es gibt die ersten
fragen bei uns im stream maximilian bei
youtube fragt sich wäre taiwan überhaupt
gewillt gegen china zu kämpfen im fall
der fälle wie ist ihre einschätzung
ich bin fest davon überzeugt haben dass
die taiwanesin in jeglicher form sie
müssen nicht vorstellen was hier
passiert ähnlich wie in der ukraine das
ein großer staat von außen kommt und das
eigene leben so wie man es über lange
jahre hinweg sich aufgebaut hat und ein
freiheitliches leben das wegnehmen will
zerstören will und durch eine ganz
andere gesellschaftsordnung
brutal ersetzen also der mann sieht das
denn an den wahlergebnissen immer dann
wenn die chinesen besonders viel druck
von außen gemacht haben und das haben
sie regelmäßig in den letzten jahren
immer wenn also der falsche kandidat urs
nicht
antrat dann hat der druck auf taiwan mit
militärischen mitteln zum gegenteil
geführt nämlich dass die kräfte den
teilwahlen gestärkt worden die für ein
freies unabhängiges china stehen würden
also ich würde hier so gut die frage was
verständlich die frage ist klar sagen
dass china
also ich kann keinen gewinn keine harz
in mainz kampagne hier gewinnt gefahren
hat man sich jetzt schon mehrfach hier
bei uns im stream gelesen habe jetzt
natürlich auch in anbetracht des ukraine
krieges des russischen angriffs dort im
prinzip hat man ja ein land auch
unterschätzt was passieren könnte und
jetzt gibt es fragen dazu und zwar maria
schreibt bei youtube maria marx es ist
so beunruhigend weil weniger russlands
drohgebärden vor dem angriff auf die
ukraine richtig ernst genommen haben was
wird jetzt aus taiwan in naher zukunft
also da auch die frage nach der
verbindung nimmt man china nicht ernst
genug vielleicht auch international mit
den drogen
ja also was wir heute sehen das zeigt
auch wenn das jetzt nur noch eine
fußnote sein kann natürlich dass es
etwas seltsam anmutet das über so viele
jahre hinweg
deutschlands nicht gesehen wurde was
sich dort allmählich auf tour was für
ein china
absatz haben gute autoverkäufe was sich
dort auftun was für eine art gemacht die
mit dem anspruch die geografie
der region verändern will und ich
bedanke mich für die frage die höchste
sehr gut insofern als wir nicht den
fehler machen sollten dass wir denken
soll naja taipeh ist ja von berlin 9000
km weit weg hat irgendwie alles nichts
mit uns zu tun dass das grundlegend
falsch
ostasien und die ostflanke senator sind
die spiegel achsen unserer sicherheit
sollte es tatsächlich im späteren
verlauf des jahres oder nächsten jahres
zu einem krieg kommen zwischen den usa
und china und keiner kann sagen dass ich
dieser krieg nur auf taipan naja
beziehen lese dann müsste man überlegen
was passiert dann würden die amerikaner
das tun was sie lange schon gesagt haben
nämlich ostasien als die priorität
betrachten die sich schon seit langem
als solche sehen das ist aber im
umkehrschluss nicht dass der
abschreckungskraft die
abschreckungskraft
der nato der amerikaner an der ostflanke
der nato entsprechend schwächer wäre
wesentlich geschwächt werde was hieße
das für unsere sicherheit für unsere
europäische sicherheit ich glaube ich
hier liegen ganz schwierige fragen bei
denen ein militärisch weiterhin nicht
sondern durch starkes europa oder
amerika
vor ganz ganz dramatischen strategischen
herausforderungen stunde weil sich an
dem charakter des russischen regimes bis
dahin nichts geändert hat wir können
gleich nochmal auf genau diese themen
näher eingehen wir haben aber auch das
passt dazu einen beitrag vorbereitet wie
das also aussehen könnte wenn china
ernst macht und auch wie die usa als
militärmacht da gegenüber stehen den hat
elmar theveßen für uns vorbereitet
michael jung macht sich einen kleinen
imbiss und sich dann gestärkt in die
schlacht zu stürzen der informatiker
simuliert in seiner wohnung im
kanadischen vancouver kriegsszenarien im
indopazifik und stellt sie auf youtube
er will der öffentlichkeit erklären wie
schnell die lage eskalieren kann er hat
quellen im militär und recherchiert
penibel die taktiken und waffensysteme
der rivale
michael zeigt uns eine simulation mit
einem realen ausgangspunkt
fast jede woche dringend chinesische
kampfflugzeuge in den luftraum um taiwan
ein
ständige provokationen manchmal 20 30
jets und bomber gleichzeitig in dieser
zusammensetzung könnten sie
amerikanische flottenverbände nahe
taiwan überraschend angreifen
es käme zunächst zum luftkampf beide
seiten hätten wohl heftige verluste
dann aber würde china landgestützten
raketen einsätzen über die es erst seit
wenigen jahren verfügt
immer wieder in michaels simulationen
verliert die amerikanische marine das
gefecht der flugzeugträger und ein teil
der begleitschiffe würden ausgeschaltet
bahn frei für den einmarsch in taiwan
ich hoffe sehr dass es nicht ein heißer
krieg wird ein echter konflikt aber ich
halte das für möglich weil bei
wachsenden spannungen ein kleiner
zufälliger vorfall geschehen kann der
dann weiter eskaliert
solche kriegsszenarien im indopazifik
spielte im herz 2020 das
us-verteidigungsministerium einfach mal
durch die simulationen ließen alle
alarmglocken schrillen immer wieder
siebter china seitdem fällt das pentagon
mit hochdruck an neuen taktiken für
mögliche waffen gehen
noch sind die usa die größte
militärmacht der welt ihr veritas ist
mit 740 milliarden dollar fast drei mal
so groß wie der chinesische bei
flugzeugträgern hat amerika in den
deutlichen vorsprung
aber chinas marine ist mittlerweile mit
350 schiffen die größte der welt mit 66
u-booten fast so viele wie die us navy
china sieht sich selbst als führende
macht dieser welt und zur mitte des
jahrhunderts werden sie diesen anspruch
nur schwer verwirklichen können ohne
teilen zu erobern
härtetest für amerikas neuesten
flugzeugträger militärisch haben die usa
noch die nase vorn und hoffen dass china
sich abschrecken lässt von einem krieg
im indopazifik
hast es ihre einschätzung auf diese
frage lässt sich china abschrecken wir
gerade gehört wir stark militärisch
militärisch china aufgestellt ist mir
statt die usa aber würde sich china
davon abschrecken lassen ihre
einschätzung
abschreckung hat viele komponenten was
wir gesehen haben war ein sehr
sehr begabter student wünschte sich dass
ich davon mehr in deutschland herum
tummelten haben
die abschreckung die
amerika liefern kann ist natürlich in
aller erster hinsicht erstmal die das
amerika das hat was china nicht hat das
sind starke verbündete nichts über
amerika gehören japan australien europa
die
szenarien die angedeutet werden sind ja
in ihrer entwicklung erkennbar messbar
dementsprechend würden in jedem schritt
der dort passiert hin in richtung einer
eskalation soll sich china tatsächlich
an diesen schritt machen und ich könnte
mir vorstellen dass es das im nächsten
jahr
gebe es im vorfeld viele möglichkeiten
wie man china technologisch
wirtschaftlich
finanziell ganz erheblich schwächen
könnte nicht die straße von malakka
ich kann man auch einfach schließen und
man kann auch das wofür er von china
abhängig ist nämlich viele es waren
einfuhren also eine sehr leichte form
der macht das kann man auch kappen und
wenn man dazu setzt das amerika
weiterhin die stärkste militärmacht der
welt ist mit einem umfang der eben um
das weiterer ist was andere staaten in
der region können beitragen können dann
würde ich mich nicht so verengen auf
diesen ein insel kampf der von hier gut
nachgezeichnet wurde aber der durchaus
einige vorbedingungen hat an denen
amerika ganz erhebliches sein gewicht in
die waagschale werfen kann
ganz viele fragen an sie im stream
gerade und zwar von der zweite er fragt
sich warum wollen die usa unbedingt
helfen
ja das ist eine gute frage die wird auch
in washington diskutiert genauso wie in
washington das gegenwärtig zwar eine
kleine fraktion gibt lehre die fragen
was haben wir mit europa zu tun nicht
also das ist der der ganz harte rechte
flügel der republikaner warum müssen wir
europa verteidigen
man muss das glaube ich so sehen oder
man kann es so sehen haben würde amerika
dies nicht tun
wäre das ein zeichen dass der schwäche
nicht das amerika das nicht kann die
wahrnehmung dass es eine sehr kern
einsichten die die wissenschaft bereitet
die wahrnehmung von schwäche unter
großmächten führt immer dazu dass sie
von anderen ausgenutzt wird würde also
amerika kairo angehen lassen haben und
die
in den machtbereich chinas wechseln
lassen könnte man davon ausgehen was
genau das dann weiter probiert wurde von
china in anderen teilen des ostens
südchinesischen meeres insofern ist teil
der kristallisationspunkt einer größeren
auf seiner sitzung bei dem es darum geht
ob china sich etablieren kann als
hegemon oder ob amerika secunia
bestellung beibehält darum geht es es
gibt auch noch mehr eine detailfrage die
ein bisschen zugespitzt ist von miro
bastians bei youtube er möchte wissen
sind atomwaffen der usa an taiwan
stationiert und verfügt china auch über
atomwaffen atomwaffen also ersteres nein
keine atomwaffen es gibt ja also eine
kleine schar an amerikanische soldaten
aber ist keine atomwaffen
china hat ein sehr stark wachsendes
atomares
arsenal wir können ungefähr davon
ausgehen dass es gegenwärtig 300 hat 300
+ haben das klare ziele chinesin ist
diese anzahl erheblich wachsen zu lassen
und was daran sehr bedenklich ist dass
die kooperationen auf lokaler ebene mit
russland
nachdem was man wissen kann wohl sehr
stark intensiviert worden ist in den
letzten jahren und dadurch eine eine
freund eine nukleare front entsteht die
man als atomwaffenfreies land das wir
jetzt deutschland sind entweder nicht
versteht oder aber das wäre strategisch
besser
als tatsächlich bedrohung sieht dann
vielleicht den letzten punkt hier nun ja
ich will noch mal darauf zurückgehen
nicht inwieweit diese beiden regionalen
h plätze also die ost ukraine el dia
dieser die ostrocker der nato und das
aus der asiate ausziehen wie die
miteinander verbunden sind wir dürfen
nicht den fehler machen diese beiden zu
trennen weil das zum krieg kommt in
ostasien bedeutet das eine schwächung
der abschreckungskraft der nato und der
usa für europa darüber muss man sich als
deutschland und europa ganz klar
gedanken machen ich sehe doch nicht dass
das ausreichend getan wurde
und wir haben im beitrag ja trotzdem
auch gelernt wenn wir noch mal ganz kurz
bei den details auch bleiben und der
militärischen stärke wenn man so gelernt
china hat nun die landgestützten raketen
ist die größte maschine der welt und es
passt dazu die frage von paul 66 10 bei
youtube er fragt kann chinesische
kriegstechnik wirklich amerika
amerikanische technik übertrumpfen
sowohl waffensysteme auf basis eines
jetzt oder auch auf basis eines
helikopters acht jets meinte
wahrscheinlich sind mehr war nicht
kriegs erprobt und weiterentwickelt also
die frage an sie kein chinesischer
kriegstechnik wirklich amerikanische
technik übertrumpfen
naja also was wir sehen ist dass amerika
die technik die es hat seit 70 jahren
plus
kontinuierlich verbessert hat also die
amerikanischen kriegs geräte die in der
region sind ob das zu luft oder zur asse
unter wasser ist ob das raketensystem
sind naja das ist zweifellos das beste
was es gegenwärtig gibt und das heißt
aber nicht dass mögliche gegner nicht
auch adaptiv lernen kann sich hier
versuchen know-how abzugucken bisher
mussten die chinesen das stark sich von
den russen ab kopenhagen das aber
gleichzeitig weiterentwickelt haben mit
ihrer einschätzung die sagen dass die
gerade in der in der marine
zum beispiel in der sparte zerstören das
eine fast parität in der qualität dieser
waffensysteme gibt also
technologischer fortschritt dauert immer
nur relativ kurz ich glaube die
erfahrung die in der technischen
entwicklung steht und weiterentwicklung
plus
die schiere wille das ist etwas sicher
was man bei all den zahlen und details
nicht vergessen darf der schiere wille
militärische gewalt eben auch anwenden
zu wollen und das zu können ich glaube
dass etwas was die amerikaner den den
chinesen weit voraus haben wer noch nie
in den letzten 40 jahren eine größere
schlacht geschlagen
so sollten müssen in dieser sendung auch
noch über ein weiteres wichtiges thema
eine verbindung in dieser in diesen
ganzen konflikt sprechen es gibt nämlich
auch einige fragen dazu nämlich um die
wirtschaftlichen verflechtungen und
auswirkungen die das ganze natürlich
haben könnte denn klar auch die
weltwirtschaft hat zu tun oder wird zu
tun bekommen mit auswirkungen wenn das
zu einem noch größeren konflikt kommt
denn die taiwan straße also die meerenge
zwischen china und taiwan ist eben diese
straße wo fast die hälfte hälfte aller
containerschiffe weltweit durch muss und
somit hat natürlich unsere wirtschaft
auch damit zu tun und es gibt hier auch
schon kommentare dazu die ich gerne mal
dazu vorlesen möchte und zwar von
anatolien bei facebook sie schreibt
taiwan hat einen trumpf in der hand
halbleiter und chips das ist nämlich ein
ein großes exportprodukt von taiwan
china wird nicht angreifen dass ihre
vermutung dass überlegen sie sich was
ist denn ihre einschätzung dazu eben
wegen dieser wirtschaftlichen
verflechtungen die cia in beide
richtungen gibt import export zwischen
taiwan und china würden sie sich das
wirklich auch deshalb noch mal zwei mal
überlegen dreimal überlegen
wie ich das vorher gesagt habe was wir
jetzt und hier heute sehen ist ein
notwendiger weise
nationalistisches
drohgebärden tun um die scharte
auszuwetzen das vocal dort sie auf der
insel war
was der punkt
gemacht wird in der frage ist das nicht
mit der halbleiterindustrie in taiwan
die weltweit führend ist qualitativ und
quantitativ natürlich ein ziel bestünde
was taiwan als chat nutzen könnte um dem
wort zu bleiben um sich dadurch zu
verteidigen zu sagen wenn ihr uns
zerstört dann zerstört der rolle ganz
der computerindustrie und kein einziger
computer wird er in zukunft
funktionieren wollte das so jetzt muss
man überlegen inwieweit diese argumente
tatsächlich tragen wir haben diese
argumente finden viele reformen bruch
gegen russland gehört zweifellos in
russland ein technologisch wesentlich
schwächeres land aber russland hat
entgegen aller wirtschaftlichen bedenken
und gedanken die lage in deutschland
über viele viele jahre hinweg geführt
worden hat es den krieg angefangen
es gibt also antriebsmomente gerade bei
großmächten revisionistische natur die
weil sie eben die geschichte neu
gestalten wollen die geschichte
vielleicht auch zurückdrehen wollen die
zu mitteln greifen die eben nicht auf
gewinn ausgerichtet sind sondern auf
zerstörung um einen gewissen haben
historischen sieg herbeizuführen
das darf uns leider nicht mehr als
irrational und absurd vorkommen das ist
leider in manchen köpfen und das
denkmuster was dort die veiling antriebe
und auch um das noch mal kurz bei der
wirtschaft zu belassen auch unsere
wirtschaft ist natürlich englisch knüpft
an die chinesische im exportmarkt und
dazu passt die frage von karl ende der
sich fragt herr der halle wie weit
glauben sie wird die deutsche
handelspolitik in der china krise
beeinflusst
eine sehr gute frage wir sind natürlich
in den köpfen
immer noch in einer welt in der china
eben einen riesen absatzmarkt für für
deutschland ist es gibt da umdenken in
der deutschen industrie und der
deutschen wirtschaft aber der
absatzmarkt china ist gewaltig groß
nicht nur der jahre hinweg kritiklos
haben egal ob das minderheiten der guten
waren oder dass der magische anspruch
als solcher gesehen jetzt stehen wir vor
dem ja ich will noch nicht sagen
scherbenhaufen aber vor dem sattel
realität die eine ganz andere ist als
die diverser vorgemacht haben so dass
das was auch die deutsche wirtschaft
gegenüber zuvor auf der was auch die
deutsche wirtschaft zu laufen könnte
fasst dieses trösten könnte die frage
ist wie kann man das beeinflussen und da
bin ich sehr kritisch an die
machtpolitischen spieler in der region
sind einzeln allein die usa und china
deutschland kann gegebenenfalls und
wirtschaftlichen druck versuchen haben
mich hinein andere richtung zu lenken
militärisch oder strategiespiele
deutschland leider in der region keine
rolle
ich versuche noch mal so viele fragen
wie möglich hier im chat mitzunehmen
jetzt zum ende der sendung wir müssen
auch bei zum ende kommen aber die finde
ich noch ich es sind viele gute frage
aber die sind auch noch einige besonders
spannend denn der besuch von nancy
pelosi der ja zumindest für jetzt unser
gespräch heute auch ein stein des
anstoßes war bzw die reaktion chinas
natürlich aber dazu passt die frage von
ines kaspar emil keyser hatte youtube er
fragt sich wie empfinden die
indopazifischen nationen den besuch
polos oder im weiten sinne die
einflussnahme der usa welches narrativ
dominierend dort pro china pro westen
es ist ein gespaltene sicht in
sicherheitsfragen
lehnt man sich gerne auf die seite
amerikas
weil nur dort der ernsthafte rückhalt
geboten wird in wirtschaftlichen fragen
in der wirtschaftliche verflechtung will
man natürlich versuchen mit china weiter
in den handel zu betreiben den mann
betrieben hat
es scheint dass diese haben zusammen
chips ist die frage um taiwan die sich
jetzt ergeben dass die einmal mehr nicht
china helfen weil die kleineren staaten
die zb in der asien-gruppe zusammentun
gesehen einmal mehr trotz aller
gegenläufigen bekundungen chinas das
kleinere staaten eben wenn sie nicht dem
willen chinas entsprechen genau in die
mangel genommen werden die teile
angenommen wird und das ist etwas ich
glaube dass es das machen die chinesen
sehr unklug aber ich habe es vorher
gesagt dass sie folgen einem antrieb
einem nationalistischen antrieb der
nicht zwingend kooperativ von der auch
nicht
zwingend haben rational aus unserer
sicht ist nicht aus chinesischer sicht
ist das ein herrlicher rational und
deshalb bin ich fest davon überzeugt
dass die staaten die kleineren staaten
einmal mehr den warnschuss jetzt
verstehen werden dass mit china nicht
wenn man so will nicht gut kirschen
essen ist wenn es um fragen der
souveränität geht
ich würde noch jetzt die letzte frage
zum schluss stellen und findet die auch
nochmal recht spannend wir haben schon
klar immer wieder darüber gesprochen
auch jetzt in dieser sendung kann sich
china den die eskalation wirtschaftlich
leisten aber hier wird noch mal die
quasi die erweitung gemacht und kann
china sich das auch überhaupt leisten in
bezug auf wahlen also wahlen des
chinesischen präsidenten wie kommt das
im eigenen land an
ja wahlen müsste man sich hier natürlich
wenn es um kinder geht möchten in
dreifacher anführungszeichen setzen es
gibt keine freien wahlen wie bei uns es
gibt eine kommunistische partei und die
wird wir haben mit großer mehrheit
bestimmt der führer dieser partei lässt
sich ernennen
dafür tut er jetzt alles um die
nationalistischen gemüter so positiv zu
stimmen dass die stimmung im land sich
dann eher hineinträgt in das gremium von
sieben personen das ihnen ernennen wird
im herbst also
was wir häufig hier übersehen ist dass
der nachteil eines solchen
autokratischen system ist macht es einen
fehler einen großen fehler filters alles
direkt auf den einen mann an der spitze
shipping zurück dass es in der comic
krise so passiert denn das ist jetzt in
der wirtschaftlichen misere haben oder
zumindest nicht in dem wirtschaftlichen
wachstum was er sich gedacht hatte jetzt
erkennbar es fällt alles auf ihn zurück
das heißt größe entscheidungen größerer
natur die er trifft ein kriegseintritt
werden solche haben die nicht zu dem
ergebnis führen nicht zu dem positiven
ergebnis führen
die fallen auf ihn negativ zurück und
das ist auch wieder nicht die analogie
die hier zu russland so wichtig ist wie
pink ganz genau ja inwieweit das
kriegsgeschehen der kriegsverlauf in der
ukraine putin stärkt oder schwächt und
wir sehen auch hier nicht ein mann putin
entscheidet darüber wie die entwicklung
vor sich geht und genau so sieht das
schwieriger weiß fängt er den krieg an
muss er ihn gewinnen das er überlegte
hoffentlich dreimal ob er es wirklich
tut noch ganz kurz die einschätzung von
ihnen zum schluss glauben sie dass das
manöver so wie jetzt auch angekündigt
von seiten chinas wirklich am sonntag
zunächst erst mal endet
großmächte dieser natur wir spielen
schlecht schlicht mit mit kleinen
staaten sind für sie
elemente der weltpolitik die
domestiziert werden muss mit den brutal
umgegangen wird und wenn das 2 3 tage
länger sind bisschen die chinesen wir
sind sicher dass die gasreserven
mental waren ungefähr elf tage halten
werden und man kann natürlich auch diese
manöver leicht mal verlieren auf sieben
acht oder neun tage um den schmerzpunkt
der taiwaner
sofa zu machen dass sie ihre lektion aus
sicht chinas
also insofern ich glaube weil das am
montag aufhört aber dir das nicht selber
offen zu halten und damit den druck und
die angst zu fördern dabei war ich
glaube das würde ich bei dir ein
augenzwinkern kosten um das vielleicht
ein zwei tage zu verlängern
sagt professor maximilian der halle der
militärexperte der uns heute all unsere
fragen und es waren viele beantwortet
hat vielen dank für ihre zeit sehr gute
führung
und auch vielen dank an euch natürlich
für diese vielen fragen und für die
aufmerksamkeit max crew und er sich
schreibt bei youtube das klingt alles
brandgefährlich das kann man so sagen
und wir beenden jetzt aber damit erstmal
diesen stream für heute und natürlich
seid ihr immer gut informiert bei uns
bei zdf heute online auch jetzt am
wochenende wie das ganze weiter geht das
chinesische militär manöver rund um
taiwan deswegen schaut da gerne vorbei
und wir sagen tschüss für heute bis
dahin tschüss